[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome, everyone.
Today we are excited
to welcome the founder
and CEO of DO Cookie Dough
Confections, Kristen Tomlan.
Welcome.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Thank you.
SPEAKER: In 2014, Kristen
decided to officially launch
DO, as she uncovered a
market of cookie dough lovers
in the world just like herself.
The increase in
demand soon prompted
Kristen to open her first
brick-and-mortar experience
here in New York City in 2017.
Since, Kristen has been a
nominee of Crain's 40 under 40,
and received brand praise among
publications such as the "New
York Times," "O, The
Oprah Magazine," "People,"
and across shows such as
"Today" and "CBS This Morning."
Today Kristen has developed
over 100 hand-crafted flavors,
including top sellers such
as signature chocolate chip--
which is my favorite--
cake batter, heavenly,
and confetti,
some of which she will
showcase here at Google today.
So how did DO start?
Like where did this
idea come from?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: So I
had been a cookie dough
lover my entire life.
I learned the ins and
out of the kitchen
from my mom, who is
a baker and a chef.
I grew up in St. Louis,
so from the Midwest.
And we made everything
from scratch.
And so cookies
were no different.
I would love sharing just
anything sugary with others
for birthdays or any occasion.
And any time that we
baked cookies at home
it was a requirement to
save my dad a Tupperware
container of cookie dough.
So that when he came home and
saw the fresh-baked cookies
on the counter, he
immediately went to the fridge
and got the cookie dough.
And even though you weren't
supposed to eat cookie dough
it was worth the risk
for me growing up.
And it just continued to be kind
of a secret obsession of mine.
Throughout college I always
had a tub of Toll House
or whatever I could
get my hands on.
And even after college I
was continuing to bake.
I was working here
in New York City.
And I treated cookie dough
like it was ice cream.
So I would some in my
fridge at all times
and take it out by the
spoonful-- a little bit--
and then stick the
container back.
So that was my experience
with cookie dough.
But I came up with
the idea for dough
when I was with a
bunch of girlfriends.
We were visiting a friend in
graduate school at Villanova,
and we happened to go
to this cookie shop.
And they had a ton of
fresh-baked cookies,
and all sorts of flavors.
And I had wandered over
to their freezer section,
and they were selling their
cookie dough and chocolate
chip for you to, of
course, go home and bake.
But I turned to my
friends and said,
hey, will anybody
split this with me.
I kind of just want
the cookie dough.
SPEAKER: I'm sure
no one said no.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Of course not.
So everybody decided to
just walk out of there
without buying anything
that was actually baked.
And at that time
it wasn't really
acceptable like sit in
their cute little shop
and eat the cookie dough
from the container.
So we sat in the car,
and then we continued on
with our shopping or
whatever we were doing.
And we were thinking,
are we going to get sick?
Or are we going to
feel terrible later?
We didn't really care.
We just finished
the whole thing.
Just licking our fingers.
No shame.
Good girlfriends.
And that was the moment.
We were in the car.
And I thought, why
isn't this a thing?
Why can't you go to a store
and just eat the cookie dough?
We all just wanted to do it.
SPEAKER: Everybody does it.
KRISTEN TOMLAN:
Everybody does it.
SPEAKER: I don't know anyone
that's actually gotten sick.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: I
don't know anybody
that doesn't like
the cookie dough,
or doesn't try it
when they're baking.
And so that was the
moment-- like kind
of the light bulb
for me that was like,
maybe this could be a thing.
Maybe cookie dough could
be a dessert on its own.
And so that started me on my
quest to develop this brand,
and develop this product that
was completely safe to eat,
and bakeable.
So you have the
option to do both.
SPEAKER: Wow.
KRISTEN TOMLAN:
So then I decided
to launch the business online
to just test the market first,
because I had no idea
how to start a business,
let alone run a retail store,
which was the original idea.
So I launched it
online to test it.
And then from there,
once that was successful,
and I saw that there really
was this market of cookie dough
lovers that I knew coming
out of the woodwork,
I decided to open
up a store in 2017.
And that kind of catapulted
the business to the next level.
SPEAKER: And I remember I
ordered some for my team
and we waited six
weeks to get it.
I ordered it online.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KRISTEN TOMLAN:
You're so patient.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: And it was
gone in a second.
I was dying to try it.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: I always
find the people that say--
especially when we
first opened-- like oh,
I waited three hours in line.
And I know they
waited in the cold,
or they waited in the rain.
SPEAKER: I was too
lazy to do that.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: And I always
tell people thank you so much.
I'm so happy that we have such
great fans, and supporters,
and so many cookie dough lovers.
SPEAKER: What are we
going to make today?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: OK.
So today we're going to make
one of our most popular flavors.
It is our brookie dough, which
you guys have in front of you.
It's a combination of
a cookie and a brownie,
so that's why we
call it the brookie.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
You can't go wrong.
At all.
It actually started
as a seasonal flavor.
So we have 20 different
flavors at our shop.
And for those of you
who haven't been--
who don't want to wait in line--
it's set up like an
ice cream experience.
So I wanted to create something
that was familiar enough--
so everyone knows when you go
into an ice cream store you can
get it by the scoop,
you can add toppings,
you can get it in
a cup or a cone.
You can even make a
milkshake out of it.
Whatever you want to do.
But instead of ice cream
it is all cookie dough.
And two of the flavors
change every single month.
And we love to have fun
spending on the season,
and trying new flavors,
and always taking requests
from fans about
what we should have.
And we decided to have
this flavor, brookie dough,
as a seasonal for the month.
It's just our chocolate
chip and our brownie batter
swirled together in one.
And it was immediately one of
the most popular flavors, which
doesn't always happen
with a seasonal
because chocolate chip is like--
usually people go
for the classic ones.
And we took a vote on
social media and everyone
wanted brookie to
stay on the menus.
So we decided to keep it, so
now it's on our regular menu.
So I'm going to
show you guys today
how to make these two
flavors, how to combine them.
And then actually, the
brookie dough originally--
since we opened the shop--
was a bar.
So it is a brownie
on the bottom,
it's chocolate chip
cookie dough on top,
and then it's topped
with chocolate ganache.
So that was kind of the
inspiration for the flavor
in the first place.
So we're going to make
the dough version,
we're going to make
the actual brookie,
and top it with
chocolate ganache,
and then fill you guys
with all sorts of sugar.
All right.
Well, I'll let you--
SPEAKER: How's that sound?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Good.
Thank you guys for having me.
Thank you for coming.
I hope you are ready to
eat some cookie dough
and have some sugar
for breakfast.
I want this to be
very interactive,
so if anyone has questions
at any time grab the mic
and ask away.
For me, cooking and
baking is an experience
that I fell in love with because
I got to share it with others.
I love baking and cooking
with others in the kitchen,
and then sharing those
treats and seeing the smile
that it puts on people's faces.
So please, if you guys have
anything, want to get involved,
get your hands
dirty, let me know.
But yes, like you
said-- thank you
for the introduction-- my name
is Kristen Tomlan, the founder
and CEO.
I started the
business in 2014 when
I was still working full-time
at a brand consultant
here in New York.
So my old job, which I
used to call my real job
and then this was my
fake job, and then
now it's kind of
switched, I used
to work in brand
experience design.
So I was a designer
for a consultant,
and I got to work
with amazing brands
like BMW, and
Samsung, and Walmart.
And I was developing
their customer experience.
So innovating that
experience and really
working through how to
stay new and different.
And I really used that expertise
as I was developing this brand
to understand what are the
unique points of the customer
journey, what are
all the interactions.
So a lot of people assume that
I went to business school,
or had investors or
any sort of thing.
I had no idea how to
start this business,
and I did it by trial.
And the only things I
knew in the beginning
were about branding and about
baking so I started there.
The first recipe
I ever developed
was our signature
chocolate chip.
All of our recipes come
from old family recipes
that have been in my
family for years and years.
And then we've modified
them to make sure
that they're safe to eat, and
that they're also bakeable.
So should we get to it?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Awesome.
We're going to start with,
like I said, chocolate chip,
which every one of our
cooking doughs-- except
for the vegan flavors-- start
with good old-fashioned butter.
We use 100% real butter.
We don't use any sort
of margarine, or Crisco,
or anything fake.
Butter is better.
Always.
It gives your cookies
and your cookie dough
a really rich flavor,
which we like.
And also is-- for me--
makes every cookie--
you can really ta--
I like that buttery taste.
So that's exactly what we use.
We use unsalted butter.
So a lot of people don't know
that actually salted butter
typically has a higher moisture
content because of that salt.
And you don't want that
moisture in your cookies.
You want it to be
super fudgy and dense.
So don't use the salt--
salted kind.
You also have more control
over how much salt you
put in your cookie dough,
which is exactly what you
want when you're baking.
This has been softened, so I've
just left it on the counter
to get to room temperature.
This is going to be the
base of what we're making.
So we want it to be
nice, and smooth,
and creamy before we add
any other ingredients.
So I'm just going
to leave it in here.
If you read a recipe that
says cream the butter that's
exactly what we're doing.
I always recommend
using a mixer.
If you don't have a stand
mixer use a hand mixer.
It just makes your
life a lot easier.
Then it will allow the flavors
to really come together,
and make sure that the
butter and the sugars
are creaming which are
incredibly important when
you're making cookies.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I've always--
like whenever I watch
the cooking shows
or the restaurant
shows one of the most
interesting things
is like the sourcing
of ingredients.
Because the chefs get up at
like 5:00 AM and go to the--
well, that's even pretty late to
get up-- go to the fishmongers,
buy these fish that you can't
ever buy as a home cook.
And so what I'm wondering
is like even with things
like butter there's 1,000
different brands of butter.
How do I, as a home chef-- or
how did you in your role source
your ingredients and say, oh,
this is the best better for me
to use/ Not that other
brand of butter or whatever.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
So a lot of testing goes
into all of our recipes,
and even from the beginning.
So the type of butter that we
did use is an American butter.
It's not a European butter.
It depends on how much
fat content you want.
Unfortunately, we're not going
to the farmer's market fresh
and getting the cultured
butter that's from the farmer.
I wish we could.
But butter, for me--
anytime that we can do local,
organic, we try our best.
And then it was just a
matter of a lot of testing.
So there's a ton of
different sugars,
a ton of different flours
that you can add in baking--
vanillas, extracts,
all of that stuff.
And I'll talk through
some of the importance
of the other ingredients
as we go through it,
and why we chose certain ones.
But because our cookie dough
is edible and bakeable,
it's a lot about the texture
of how things come together
when you're eating it raw
and when you're baking it.
It's not just one or the other.
And then also for us,
and any food business,
perishability is
obviously something
that we need to think about.
So making sure that our
ingredients are top quality,
to make sure that they
will last for consumers
in the fridge, and in the
freezer, and all of the ways
that we recommend cooking
them or eating them.
So we got the butter--
the best part.
Next, we're going
to add the sugar.
So this particular
recipe uses a combination
of white sugar,
which is granulated
sugar and brown sugar.
For those of you who
don't know, brown sugar
is white sugar with
added molasses.
More molasses you have
a darker sugar, so dark
brown sugar just
has more molasses.
For this, we're going to
use light brown sugar.
And it uses 75% brown sugar.
So the brown sugar is
typically what people mostly
associate with eating
chocolate chip cookie dough.
It's that molasses-ey
flavor that most people
love and is super nostalgic.
So we really up the
amount of brown sugar
that we use in this recipe.
We use 75% brown sugar
and 25% white sugar.
The white sugar is going
to help things spread,
and the brown sugar is going
to be an acid in this recipe.
And it's going to
mix with a base
that we're going to add later.
So cooking is a little
bit of chemistry,
or baking at least is a
little bit of chemistry.
It's not as easy to just
dump a little bit of this
and a little bit of that, and
substitute here and there.
So what we're doing is just
creaming the butter and sugar.
We want to just let this
go and get nice and smooth.
We want it to be all one
color and all one texture.
The sugar are these
little granules--
and what you want
to do when you're
making cookie dough is
you want to envision
just coating each one of
those little things of sugar
with butter Read
and just making sure
it's a nice smooth texture.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Since you've
had so much success
from your first
store opening in 2017
do you have any
plans to franchise?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: We get
thousands of requests
to franchise, especially since
we've opened, which is amazing,
because it just means that
so many other people relate
to this concept and can
see it being popular
in their city or their town.
Right now we are so
busy, and my team
is so busy, that I don't want
to take a minute of our time
to figure out the franchising.
I think we'll do a few more
company-owned stores before we
actually franchise it out.
This is very much like my baby.
And I have a very hard
time letting go of--
handing it over to somebody else
to just kind of run with it.
And that would always be
my worry with franchising.
But I will never say
never to anything.
I'm always keeping options open.
So I certainly
think that it could
be a possibility down the line.
OK.
So we got the butter and sugar.
The next ingredients
that we're going to add
are liquid ingredients.
And I want to talk about
these for a couple of reasons.
One, going back to
your sourcing question.
Our vanilla.
We use a 100% vanilla--
pure vanilla extract.
It comes from Madagascar.
We have tested a ton
of vanilla-- some
from Mexico, some from Tahiti.
And Madagascar, for us, is
really the best of the best.
So I always
recommend when you're
baking, and for at-home chefs,
to go for the good vanilla.
It will yield a
better smoother flavor
in whatever you're baking.
And typically a
bottle of it at home
will go a long way
because you only
use a teaspoon or a
tablespoon here or there.
So it is expensive, but
it is really worth it.
We use even more
vanilla in this recipe
because we like
that flavor-- how
it mixes with the brown sugar.
So that is why this
is-- liquid is brown.
The other ingredient
in here is our egg.
Most people assume that
because our cookie dough
is safe to eat--
I'm just going to
very slowly pour
this in to avoid it
spraying up in my face
and giving me an egg facial.
Good.
The other ingredient is the egg.
So most people assume
that our cookie dough
is safe to eat-- we
just eliminate the egg
and therefore you're good to go.
You can just eat
it from the bowl.
That's actually not
the case at all.
There are other
ingredients in cookie dough
that I'll talk about in a
bit that can make you sick,
besides just eating raw eggs.
In the United States,
as many of you know,
salmonella would be
the bacteria that you
could get from eating raw eggs.
But our eggs are
completely safe to eat.
They're good in
this cookie dough
and you could put
it in your smoothie
if you wanted more protein.
It's been pasteurized.
So that means it's been heated
to a specific temperature
to kill the bacteria, and
then cooled back down.
And it retains its normal
properties of an egg.
So if you were to stick
this in a hot saucepan
it would make scrambled
eggs, which people are always
surprised about.
But in cookie dough we don't
want to make scrambled eggs.
We want it to be used
as a binding agent.
So it's going to keep
everything together.
It's also going to add some
extra flavor that you otherwise
would miss.
When I was recipe testing I
tried every egg substitute out
there.
And every single time
it never stood up
to the real egg, the real deal.
So I decided to scrap
all of those substitutes
and find an egg that was
completely safe to eat.
So that is our egg.
That's the liquid ingredients
which we just added.
And now we want to
just whip it until it's
really light and
fluffy to make sure
that all gets incorporated.
This mixer is great.
I'm not having to scrape it
down at all because the bowl is
really high.
But sometimes when
you're baking you
might have to stop,
scrape things down, just
to get it all incorporated.
So when I originally started the
business, I was-- like I said,
I was working full-time.
And I think that--
I think I was nervous because no
one else had really done this.
We get so many people now that
are like, oh, why didn't I
think of this?
This is such a great idea.
Like, you know, everybody's
been eating cookie dough.
But when I first
started the business
I didn't know, honestly, if
it was really going to work.
I thought maybe somebody--
this hasn't been done before
because it can't be done.
Maybe people won't
respond to it well.
Maybe there is this
stigma that even
if with-- through
education people
won't be able to get
over the egg thing,
or the worry of getting sick.
It's just a completely different
model from an ice cream
store or a traditional bakery.
So it was difficult as I was
working on this business plan
to try and figure out
how it would work,
and what would be popular,
and what wouldn't be popular.
So that's why I decided
to start it online
and just take baby
steps-- kind of
get my feet wet
with the production,
and understanding what
the market looks like.
And luckily, the market
was amazing almost
from the beginning.
I think with the
power of social media,
and people sharing
what they're doing,
especially this like
foodie culture in New York,
it really worked
to our advantage.
And it's been a really
crazy ride, but really fun.
Next ingredients
we're going to add.
So it's a small amount of
questionable white powder.
It's all legal substances.
The first thing is really
easy to understand.
It is our sea salt.
So we use sea salt.
It's a less refined
salt so it has
a little bit of mineralities
in it which we like.
And Additionally, it is
going to be baking soda.
So baking soda is the base
in this specific recipe.
It's going to mix
with the acid that
is the molasses and
the brown sugar.
It's going to create
carbon dioxide.
Without boring you, it will help
your cookies rise in the oven.
If you put too much baking
soda in your cookie dough
it's going to taste
like a bar of soap,
or like baking soda
toothpaste, which is the worst.
So you have to really balance
how much you're putting in
to make sure that it's reacting,
and make sure you don't taste
it in the actual cookie dough.
And then the third ingredient.
One of our secrets is a
little bit of cornstarch.
So cornstarch is going to be
also used as a binding agent
and as a leavener.
So we like our cookies when they
bake to be extra super soft.
I'm not a thin crunchy
cookie kind of gal,
and you won't find thin
crunchy cookies at DO.
You will find nice and thick,
kind of crispy on the outside
with that golden brown
outside, and nice,
and gooey, and
chewy on the inside.
And that cornstarch
in the cookie dough
will allow you to get that
soft-baked cookie texture.
So I'm going to just
add these in now.
You can whisk it
together with your flour,
but I'm going to
just do it first just
to make sure it's really well
incorporated in the dough.
Because it is a
small amount of stuff
you just want to make sure
it's evenly distributed
so that those
reactions can happen,
and all of those flavors
are really coming together.
AUDIENCE: So I'm really curious.
You're sort of targeting
both, you know,
making them delicious
when they're baked,
and making them delicious
as cookie dough.
And are there trade-offs
here, where you could maybe
make more delicious cookie dough
by not making them as good when
they're baked or vise versa?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: So when I was
experimenting-- or actually,
when I was--
before I even came
up with the idea
there were specific
recipes that we would
make at home with my mom that
were really good as cookie
dough, and not as good as
cookies, or vise versa--
really good as cookies and
not as good as cookie dough.
But my dad wanted
the good stuff.
And we always baked it
and we always kept it raw.
And so we found a recipe that
was the perfect mix of both.
And so that is
kind of the recipe
that we went off of
for the development.
I think that there
could be ways depending
on how rich you want it or the
consistency that you want it.
But for me, what
was important is
to really give people a full-on
cookie dough experience.
So a lot of people when they
eat our dough with a spoon
they're surprised.
Like, oh, this tastes
just like cookie dough.
And I'm like, yeah,
it is cookie dough.
It's exactly what it is.
It's much more rich
than an ice cream.
It's more dense.
So if you were to stick any of
our cookie dough in the oven
it would bake.
So I always tell
people if you save it
for later if you can't
finish it it will last
in the fridge or the freezer.
You can always take
it home and bake it.
Or mix it with ice cream.
That way you don't have to--
I was always the one picking
around the ice cream,
and just eating the cookie
dough out, and then leaving
the rest for my
husband to basically
have a pint of vanilla ice
cream, which no one actually
wants.
Next ingredient.
So I'm going to talk
about the flour.
So as most people know, eating
raw eggs could be harmful.
There could be salmonella.
Don't eat cookie dough.
We've heard all of that.
What a lot of people don't know
is that raw flour could also
harbor bacteria.
So if you think
about it, flour is
a raw agricultural ingredient.
So it's grown in
the field somewhere,
and there's really
not a ton of control
over what birds fly over, or
what critters may or may not
crawl in.
And typically during
the milling process--
when you harvest the wheat
and you make it into flour--
there isn't a step
in that process which
kills any potentially harmful
bacteria that those critters
could have left behind, which
is gross to think about.
It then goes to you, sits on
your counter for six months.
That bacteria
continues to harbor.
But as soon as you
cook it-- you bake it,
you fry it, you
heat it in a pan.
Whatever you're doing
that's the kill step
that kills that potentially
harmful bacteria.
So you don't even know if
your flour had bacteria
or not because you heated it.
But with the rise
of people eating
cookie dough, and brownie
batter, and cake batter,
more people are
licking the spoon.
And the bacteria is
not from the egg.
It comes from the flour.
So that obviously poses a
risk for people at home.
So we did such an extensive
amount of research
we actually were one
of the first people
to bring this to
the New York market.
So some of the large cookie
dough and other manufacturers
were using heat-treated flour
when I started this business
in 2014, but it was nearly
impossible to get as a small
producer that
might-- our minimum--
we didn't have room to have
pallets and pallets of this,
let alone go through it all.
So that was one of
the biggest challenges
as I was starting the business--
is finding a distributor
to carry the product, bring
it in specifically for us
so that we could make our
cookie dough safe to eat.
So the flour that we're using
is a heat-treated flour.
It's been through the process,
like the pasteurization
process, to make sure
that all of that bacteria
no longer exists.
It's tested like the egg is
tested before it comes to us.
And then, again, it's
just like a normal flour.
So you can use it
in your cookie dough
and you don't have to
worry about getting sick.
The other unique thing
about this specific flour
is that we make our
own blend of AP flour.
So there are a ton of
different flours out there.
Two basic ones mostly
boils down to a hard flour
and a soft flour.
And the difference
between those flours
are about where they're
grown, when they're grown,
and when they're harvested.
And how much gluten
is in those flours.
So all-purpose flour
is a mix of both.
Soft flour is also
known as cake flour
and is really great
for anything that you
want to be light and fluffy.
Like French pastries or cake.
The other kind, hard flour,
has a higher gluten content
and is great for
breads and pizza dough.
It's going to give you that
stretchiness that everyone
loves to kind of bite into.
And for cookies you just want
to use a mix of both of those.
So that your cookies aren't
too dainty and crumbly,
and you also--
they're not too
tough or stretchy.
So we mix our own
proprietary blend
of all-purpose flour in house.
It was a process that
we tested extensively
to have the exact texture that
we want for the cookie dough
and for the cookies.
So that is what we have here.
It is our blend of AP flour.
It's heat-treated.
And I'm just going to add
this in little by little.
You don't really notice any
sort of taste difference
in the heat-treated.
You might notice
if you smell it.
A little bit of
a toasted flavor,
because that's essentially
what they're doing
when they're heat treating it.
But when it's mixed with
all of the other ingredients
and cookie dough you would
never notice any difference
whatsoever.
So add this little by little.
This is the final step.
The recipe that we're
making technically
is in the category of cookies
called a drop cookie recipe.
And a drop cookie
recipe is a recipe
that most people make
at home, and most people
are used to eating.
Or sneaking from the bowl.
It's the kind of cookie that you
drop on a sheet and then bake.
You don't have to roll it out.
You don't have to cut it out.
You don't have to do all
of these other things
that some other cookies--
pipe or anything else.
And drop cookie recipes
are great because they're
pretty easy to go
together once you
have all of the ingredients
measured out, which
is half the battle.
You just throw it in the
mixer like this, similar to--
you always start with the fat.
In our case, butter.
Then you do sugars,
liquid ingredients,
and then dry ingredients.
And the good thing is that
it all comes together,
and you really--
it's hard to mess up
if you've measured correctly.
The only thing you
can do is over mix it.
So once it's like
good you can just
keep going along
with the process.
And especially once
you add the flour in,
because the flour
adds the gluten.
Once it's mixed you
can just be done,
and you don't have to let it
keep going forever and ever
like you would potentially
with a meringue,
or with whipped
cream or something.
You don't need to
add any extra air
because we want our cookies to
be nice, and dense, and fudgy.
And the more you mix it the
more it activates that gluten,
and your cookies can get tough.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Did you
have another question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: What's
your name, by the way?
AUDIENCE: My name is James.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So you've came in
with the recipes
from when you were
growing up and also
through developing
them as you started
thinking about the business.
And you had the
marketing knowledge
from your previous work.
But one of the things
I've always heard
is that one of the hardest parts
about building a restaurant
is the actual business--
the accounting.
Are we actually making
a profit right now?
How do we control costs, and
get the right number of workers,
and so on and so forth.
So where-- you just picked
that up as you've gone along?
Or did you have some previous
experience in running business?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: No previous
business experience.
Luckily, my husband did
go to a business school,
not that business school teaches
you how to run a business.
He always says-- he's like,
this taught me nothing.
But it is helpful to kind
of have a sidekick in that
has at least been to school.
Not that I didn't
graduate college
and all of these things.
But to be honest,
for me, it was a lot
of just figuring out as I go.
I always tell people,
especially new entrepreneurs,
there's never a point that
you feel prepared or feel
ready to start any
sort of business.
Like you're never going to
have it all figured out.
So just do something to move
forward and you will learn.
If you are smart, if you
are a hard worker, if you
have a network of people that
you can ask-- and honestly,
google.com is like your
best friend, literally.
There's so many resources out
there to find information.
And for me, it was
incredibly helpful to start
with baby steps.
So starting online
first, figuring that out,
learning-- hiring a
few people and learning
how to manage that.
And manage production,
and ordering, and online
before I even opened the store.
And that's part
of the reason why
I launched online-- was because
the thought of opening up
a restaurant in New York City
without any business experience
or operation experience
was incredibly daunting.
And I was looking
at-- the investment
was going to be insane.
And I didn't want to be one of
those businesses that opened,
and then--
or restaurants that
you see all the time--
that it's a great location,
it's a great idea,
maybe the execution
is even pretty good.
But it just-- six
months later the doors
are closed because they
just can't make it work.
It's incredibly difficult.
But I did use the experience.
I launched in 2014 and
then didn't open the store
until 2017.
But even then, when we
first opened the store
I had no idea about
the popularity,
or like really an expectation.
I thought it was
going to be popular.
Like I told my old boss--
I was like, maybe this could be
the next big thing in desserts.
Like cupcakes have
kind of come and gone.
When I was working on this
idea in 2012 it was like--
so I was like maybe this
could be the next thing.
And I didn't know--
the story is I had five
full-time people when
I moved to the new store.
And they all were
working in the kitchen.
And one other like
assistant who did
a little bit of
everything-- business,
and kitchen, and everything.
And then when I opened
up the store-- so
we basically were
moving our kitchen.
And then we had this new
front of house element.
And so I thought, OK, I'll
hire five more people to help--
just work as hourly
employees in the front.
And then all of us-- the people
in the back, and me included--
can pop in and out, and work
up front, and just make sure
that everything's
running smoothly.
Like I'm fine checking
people out or doing
whatever we need to do.
My husband was like, you
can't afford five people.
You can only hire four.
So I'm like, fine.
OK.
I hire four people.
And even then, we spent
essentially all of the money
that we had made in
the first two years
on this new lease, new
build-out, new equipment,
new everything.
Because for me, I
was like I'm just
going to go big or go home.
Like I didn't want
to keep doing what
I was doing with just
the online orders,
and like this really
small business.
I really wanted to see where it
was going to go and just kind
of give it my all.
AUDIENCE: Sounds terrifying.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: It was
incredibly terrifying.
Yeah.
And so we hired
these four people.
And when we opened there
was a line down the block.
And I was like, how
do these people--
like what's going on?
You know?
And then I just thought--
I think there was a news
article in "New York "Magazine."
So I was like oh, they probably
learned about it through there.
And then as soon as
these people come and go
it'll be like quiet--
which it was, for
like a small amount of time.
People like trickled in all
day when we first opened.
We opened on a Wednesday?
Wednesday.
I don't even-- geez.
That whole time is
like a blur to me.
I don't think I
slept for months.
So we opened on a Wednesday.
And then my family came to
visit that first weekend
to kind of celebrate
the opening.
And in my mom's
typical fashion she
had theater tickets, and dinners
planned, and all this stuff.
And on Thursday we opened up
and the store was like slammed.
Wednesday we ran out
of a ton of stuff.
We were staying up all
night trying to remake
it to open on Thursday.
And I called my mom on Thursday.
I was like, cancel
all your plans.
Like I need you guys to
help work in the store.
Like I don't know what's
happening, but like--
I just need help.
And my family is--
they're all bakers, and cooks,
and good Midwestern folk.
Like they'll roll their sleeves
up and get their hands dirty
any time.
So they came on I
think Thursday night.
And immediately I
put them to work.
And so it was the four
employees that I hired,
my dad, my brother, my
brother-in-law, my two sisters,
my mom.
And we all took turns.
Like part of us
were in the front.
Part of us in the back.
We were just making
cookie dough.
My brother-in-law did
dishes for eight hours
straight-- the poor guy.
Love you, James.
And my parents-- my dad
scooped cookie dough.
They had like carpal tunnel
by the end of the weekend.
And they're like, we
have got to get out.
And that was the weekend that
there were four-hour lines down
the block and around the corner.
And we didn't know
what was going on.
And that was just
the very beginning.
We ran out of all
of our ingredients--
like all of our cookie dough.
Anything that was
edible was gone.
And anything that was--
we just ran out of
every single thing.
We had no flour.
And our flour-- you can't
just go to the grocery store
and get our flour or our eggs.
So we had to wait.
This was the weekend.
So we couldn't put an
order in until Monday,
so we had to wait until
Tuesday to get everything.
So-- I'm going to start on the
next one while I'm talking.
So it was kind of-- to
be honest-- a shit show.
But I learned a lot in
those first few weeks.
And then we closed the store
because we didn't have anything
to sell for the first couple--
for a Sunday and a Monday.
And I put up as
many ads as I could.
And then just-- people would
walk in and I'll be like, OK.
Do you like cookie dough?
Do you know anything
about cookie dough?
OK.
You can speak clearly.
Great.
Are you available?
You have availability.
Can you scoop cookie dough?
OK.
Show me that you
can use your hands.
You're hired.
Like that was
basically the process
in the beginning, which worked
for a time, and was great.
But obviously, we have
such a great staff
now that we're like
settled and established.
But that team of 10 I guess,
or nine, went immediately to--
within the first
four weeks after
we opened-- to about 60 people.
We started running
multiple shifts.
We were basically in
the kitchen from 5 AM
until midnight or 1:00 AM.
And then we were cleaning
from two to four.
And then the team would
come back at five.
And it was just like around
the clock and really--
it was a struggle
for many, many weeks
until we were able
to get our facility
in the Bronx open and running.
Because not only did we
not have enough people,
we didn't have enough space.
Like we didn't have
enough refrigeration.
We didn't have
enough of anything.
So we had to kind
of move off site
and immediately start
looking at other options.
What I'm making now
is our brownie batter.
So what I just put in
was melted chocolate--
semi-sweet chocolate and butter.
That's going to be
the base of this.
So this one is super fudgy.
Really like a chocolate
lover's dream.
And I'm just mixing it
with the brown sugar again
and the white sugar.
So this is going to be the base
of that brookie, and then also,
obviously, the brownie
part of the recipe.
This one is dangerous,
because this
is a recipe that I can sit
and eat like so much of.
And suddenly I'm
like, what happened?
Who ate it?
Where did it go?
You'll like scrape the bottom
of the container, especially
when it's nice and warm.
And it disappears in an instant.
So I guess my love
for unbaked things
goes far beyond
just cookie dough.
I also love brownie batter.
I love cake batter.
Anything that is
not fully baked,
kind of gooey in the
middle, is like my jam.
Actually, when I
was babysitting--
I used to do a
ton of babysitting
when I was growing up.
And this family I babysat down
the street they had five kids.
And it was like
madness at all times.
I usually have one of
my siblings with me.
And the one way to occupy their
attention was to make brownies.
So I would get two boxes of
brownies, sit the kids down,
we would have a mix.
One box would not
have the egg in it.
At this point this was so long
ago no one really kind of knew
about the flour thing.
And I would make one
box without the egg,
and just put it in
bowls, and the kids
would eat the bowls
of brownie batter.
And then the other box I would
actually make into brownies, so
that when the mom came home
there was like something
nice and fresh-baked.
And also just a--
even though sugar probably
wasn't the right thing
to give a bunch of rambunctious
kids, it was just our routine.
Every Saturday or
whenever I would
babysit we would make two
boxes of brownies and--
so this recipe, even though
it's a cookie recipe,
it is very much like the
brownie texture and flavor.
It's super fudgy with
that melted chocolate.
Other ingredients are
going to be cocoa powder.
And then those leaveners again.
And the sea salt. So this is
all gonna go in the mixer.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It seems like you've
kind of built a cookie dough
market in New York that
didn't exist before,
which is really awesome.
But now that you proved
the concepts, other--
I noticed a competitor down
the street kind of sprung up.
So has that changed
your business at all?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Honestly, no.
It hasn't really
changed the business.
Obviously, we were the first of
our kind to make this concept
and show that it could really
work, especially in New York.
And for us, we've been so
laser focused, and so busy
on growing the
business, and continuing
to expand in a number
of different ways,
that I don't have time to really
pay attention to competitors.
Of course I'm aware
that they exist.
And for me, I think
that this concept,
like I said, how
it could be kind
of the next big
thing in desserts,
I think that there's a lot
of the pie to go around.
And because we have this
presence in New York, which
is amazing, I'm encouraging
other people and other cookie
dough lovers to obviously
follow their passions.
And if they think that their
town could use a cookie dough
shop that only works better
for me, as I continue
to expand and more people learn
about this cookie dough trend.
And people always
ask like, oh, are
you worried about the people
here, the people there,
or these people are
ripping you off,
or like they're
taking your this.
I don't really have time to--
like what am I going to do?
Copy the people
who are copying me?
Like a shittier
version of myself?
Like that is a terrible idea.
Who has time for that?
So yeah.
We're continuing to expand.
We are serving more
people than ever.
I don't know if you guys
ever go to Mets games.
We have a couple of stands at
Citi Field which are really
fun, so you can get some
cookie dough at the ballpark.
We're also doing a number of
different pop-ups this summer.
So we've got our
Camp Cookie Dough,
which is at Chefs
Club Counter in Soho.
It is a summer camp-themed
cookie dough store.
So when we had this opportunity
to do something for the summer
there we thought, obviously
cookie dough is nostalgic
and it brings everybody
back to their childhood,
and that's why I think
people are like--
have this emotional connection
to what they're eating.
People also have the same
nostalgia, especially
in New York, for summer camp.
So we thought, why don't we just
kind of blow this concept up
and have all of the
desserts centered
around childhood favorites.
All of them, of course,
include cookie dough.
But all of them also include
soft-serve ice cream.
And it's a really
fun experience.
We have a pop-up in
Montauk for the summer--
if anybody is out east--
Washington, DC, and Chicago.
All the summer.
So all sorts of
fun stuff going on.
And we just launched--
ta-da-- our new baking kits.
So they're actually
coming out in August,
but we just debuted them at
Fancy Food the other week.
And the three
flavors for that are
going to be chocolate
chip brownie batter, which
are the two I'm making today.
And then sugar cookie.
And that mix-- it comes
in a box like this.
You just add two ingredients,
and then everything else
is ready to go.
The nice thing
about this product
is that it's shelf stable, if I
were to ever start another food
business.
Perishability is so-- and
refrigeration and freezing
is obviously
incredibly difficult.
So this is nice because
it has a long shelf life,
it can go in grocery stores
across the United States.
Obviously it has our
name all over it,
and is a natural kind
of brand extension.
In addition, we continue to
shop online all over the United
States.
And we have a pretty
robust catering and event
business in New York
that we ship nationwide.
And then we also go to offices
and do little cookie dough
bars.
And then at our store--
one of the most fun
things about my job
is just like interacting
with customers,
and teaching people
all the things
that I've learned
over the years.
So we just started this
baking school program.
It's called The Cookie Academy.
And you can take cookie
dough making and baking
classes in our store.
So I think we're almost good.
What I'm going to do here
is just turn on this--
if I can get it.
OK.
So all I'm going to
make here is the ganache
to top this brookie.
So what we've got is we've
got our brownie batter, which
is nice and gooey.
Tastes exactly like
brownie batter.
And we've got our chocolate
chip cookie dough.
So in order to make the
brookie, what we would do--
which we're not going to
do right this second-- is
we would take this, we would
press it down in a pan,
and we would bake it so the
bottom is a full-on brownie.
Then we would add a layer of
chocolate chip on top of that
once it's cooled.
And then stick that
back in the oven
until it gets nice and gooey,
and it's not fully baked.
And then it gets topped off
with the chocolate ganache.
So we're going to do
the ganache element.
Ganache sounds fancy.
It's not.
It's very easy.
But it's really also
super delicious.
So all you're going
to do is you're
going to heat up heavy cream.
If you can do it
in the microwave
it makes it even easier.
And then you're just going
to pour it over the chocolate
chips and let it set, and
then we'll whisk it together.
But to make the actual
brookie flavor what
we do-- since we
scoop the cookie
dough out of what looks
like gelato containers--
we would add dollops of both
of these different flavors
in the same container and
then kind of swirl around.
So if you guys can tell
from the little jars
we have in front of
you, that we like
being able to see the
chocolate chip cookie
dough and the brownie
batter cookie dough.
So it's not like a full mix.
It's really like
a swirl technique.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to fold in--
I'll do it in here
because it will
be a little bit easier to see.
I'm going to just take
some of this brownie batter
and just add a few
dollops in here.
And then we'll just
swirl it around,
and we'll have some
fresh cookie dough.
SPEAKER: When you do
the little cups do
you do equal parts
chocolate chip and brownie?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
We do.
Those cups are-- everything is
filled by hand so they might
have-- some of them might
have a little bit more
of one or the other, but we
try to do it really evenly.
And I only stirred it
one or two times and you
get this nice ribbon technique.
And we would leave
it just like this.
If we were going to bake this
into cookies all I would do
is refrigerate this cookie
dough, put Saran wrap over it,
stick it in the fridge
for as long as I
can-- at least 24 hours.
And then I would
just scoop it out
with a cookie scoop
right on a sheet tray,
and 350 in the oven
for about 10 minutes.
They make really
delicious cookies.
So that's what we got.
We got our brookie dough.
And then let's see how we're
doing with this heavy cream.
OK.
I'm just going to get this to
a boil and then turn it down.
You guys have any
questions in the meantime?
Anything else I didn't cover?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In this sort of
health-crazed market
how do you sort of
combat that, or help
people to limit the amount, if
that's something you are doing?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
So obviously-- I get
that question a lot.
Like everyone's like, oh,
it's not just gluten-free,
or vegan this, and
trying to be healthy.
People are just
trying to eliminate
fats, and sugars, and all
those things from their diet.
Certainly, we have gluten-free
flavors, and vegan flavors,
and all of that, which
are equally as delicious.
But I also think that
there's a moment in life
to treat yourself, and to
have a little bit of fun,
and indulge in something
that makes you happy.
So you all work very hard.
I work very hard.
Everybody has--
there's a lot of stuff
going on in the world
that is not pleasant.
And so if there's a
moment that you can just
put a smile on your
face and treat yourself
to whatever makes you happy--
maybe that's a yoga class,
maybe that's a spoonful
of cookie dough,
maybe it's an ice cream cone,
maybe it's none of those things
and it's like your
own personal choice.
That's what I'm all about.
It's like just making
sure that we're
putting a smile on
your face, and allowing
you to indulge in something
that you really love.
So even with all the health
craze-- like trust me,
I have to go to SoulCycle
way too often because I
eat cookie dough all day.
But I do think that
there is a moment where
you deserve a little treat
and something to smile.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for sharing your story.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah, of course.
AUDIENCE: When was that tipping
point or that moment where
you're like, I need to
make this my full-time job
and it's really time to
leave your brand background?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: So I--
so this is just really
coming to a slow boil.
And as soon as you see those
bubbles you can take it off.
And all I'm going to do is
pour it over this chocolate
and just let it
sit for a second.
So I was working full-time.
I was living the
consultant life, which
was just a difficult life
because you're traveling,
you're on the site with
the client, et cetera.
And so when I
started this business
my boss knew I was starting it.
And so once things were kind
of taking off I went to him
and I was like, Randall--
I was like, I don't
know what the--
is going on but I
just feel like I
need to dedicate more
time to this business,
and like trying
to figure it out.
And I don't know at what point
people like quit their jobs
or don't.
But like-- I don't know
that I want to quit my job.
It was very conflicting for me.
And so he was so nice,
and so encouraging.
And so originally I went down
to working two days a week,
and had a really
flexible schedule,
which helped me dedicate
more time to the business.
And I also was only on a
one final client commitment.
And as that started wrapping
up still even working
two days a week was too much.
And I found myself just really
wanting to work on the business
and it taking up
every hour of my day.
And my poor husband
hadn't slept either.
So I just went back and
I was like, look, as much
as I love my job,
and as much as this
has been such an
amazing experience--
I'd been there for five years--
I feel like now is the
time to kind of take a step
and see where this goes.
And I have never
looked back since then.
But it wasn't easy.
It was difficult.
Very difficult.
That was about six weeks after
I had launched online so--
SPEAKER: Let me join you again.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: I'll be wrapping up
and ask you a few questions.
What about the people who
were kind of sceptics,
and think this is a fad, and
how do you keep it relevant?
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yes.
OK.
So I always tell
people I obviously
did not invent cookie dough.
So cookie dough has been around
for a very, very long time.
And cookies, in general,
are such an American dessert
that people have
grown up with for--
since the 1800s, was like
when the chocolate chip
cookie really came to be.
And so I'm not pretending like
I'm creating something new.
But what I think I'm doing-- oh,
I'm making a huge mess is what
I'm doing--
is kind of reinventing it, and
making it new and different.
And serving it in a different
way, obviously, which I think
has a lot of legs because
the nostalgia factor.
So it's rare that
you find something
that so many people can
relate to on this like
emotional level
because it reminds them
of their mom, or
their grandmother,
and nostalgia goes a long way.
But I also recognize
that fads come and go,
and desserts come and go.
And so I think it's continuing
to listen to our customers,
and continuing to
innovate, and find
new ways to expand the brand.
So I'm not really concerned.
I don't think cookies are
going away anytime soon.
I don't think cookie
dough is going away.
So I think as long
as we're continuing
to stay relevant, and
be new and different,
and innovate the experience,
I think that cookie dough can
go a long way.
SPEAKER: Well, thank you
so much for joining us.
It has been so great
to have you here.
And--
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Thank you.
SPEAKER: --we cannot
wait to eat this.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Yeah.
Dig in.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
KRISTEN TOMLAN: Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]